ええええええ
[音楽]
andere
今日は小林旭ですドイツから来ました
ドイツで欧文書体のデザインをしています
欧文書体つまりアルファベット abc ですねそれを作っています
今こちらに移っている本当はこれは私の作ったものではないです
ちょっとふざけてみました
これを見た時にこの鉄塔っていうイベントとこれないようあってんのかっていうふうに
思った人いません
多分たいていの人は思ったと思うんですけれども
ちょっとふざけて作ったわけで実際のテッドのロゴはここにも後ろにもあるように
真ん中のものですよね
いろんなフォントがある中からこのあえてこのオーソドックスな形をフォントを選んで
ロゴにしています
でこの論語を選んだ理由というのはやっぱり
例えばロゴがどこで伝えたい何かがあるわけですよね
それはたとえば落ち着いて聴ける話ですよとか怖い話じゃありません以上とかそれから
まあ信頼できる内容ですよ
そんなことをこのロゴで表現したいわけです
安心かお言葉の形で表現するわけですよね
まあ変なもので場違いなものはおかしいってすぐ気づいちゃうんですよ
でも当たり前の使い方をされると当たり前すぎてそこに注意がいかないんですよね
例えばたまたまテッドには向いてないかもしれないですけれどもいろんなフォントが
あります
例えば子供受けするとか中世ヨーロッパの話ですよとかあるいはかわいい
高級感があってオシャレとかそんな
演出に向くフォントでたくさんあります目的に合っていれば使いたくなりますよね
まあ今のスライドを作っているところはこれですけれどもこんなふうにフォントを選ぶ
メニューがあって
グラフィックアプリケーションの中にね何百というデザインがあってその中から選べ
ます
フォントのでデザインという仕事について知っている人は少ないかもしれません
でもそれを作った人がいるはずで
で新しいフォント面白いフォント
場面場面で使い分けたくなりますよね
でそのじゃあ新しいフォントをつくりましょうとなった時に
デザイナーのやることフォントを作るデザイナーである事って何か
まず
大変なことがあります二つの矛盾した事を同時に実現しなくちゃいけないんですよ
たとえば文字が a なら a に読める事って大事です
自分でアルファベットの形を発明するわけじゃなくて
それを他の人が読めなかったら使い物にならないですよね
で
フォントデザイナーの作る a はだからどこかで見たことがある形でなくちゃいけ
ません
でも一方で新しいと誰もが認めるような形でなくちゃいけない
その矛盾と戦っているわけです
これは1990年代に私が作って世界的な欧文フォントのグランプリを受賞した
フォントです
これとこの次に別のフォントで別のグランプリを受賞しました
カテゴリーがいくつかあって私は一番ハードルが高いと思った
本文用書体のカテゴリーで応募しました
本文フォントですからそんなに奇抜な形はできないですよね
でどこかで読んだことのあるどこかで見たことのある形で
まあ基本的な本格的な
書籍が組めるでもグランプリを受賞したということはこれが新しい今までいないと認め
てもらったということになります
実際にフォントはいろんなところで使われていてたまたま通りかかって見つけた例です
けれどもこのパンフレットはベルギーで学校の公園に行った時に見つけました
はいこのアメリカの例はベテランのデザイナーが私のフォントを使ってくれて気に入っ
たというので
ブックデザイナーがね私のフォントを使った例と一緒に感謝の手紙とともに送られてき
ました
でこれは私のもう一つ2回目のグランプリを獲った時のフォントです
これオランダですねまあこれをきっかけになって2001年にドイツの会社に招かれ
それ以来ずっと欧文フォントのデザインのディレクションしています
さて
私は日本人ないで
しかもまあ生まれつきのバイリンガルでもなんでもないのに
29歳になるまで日本の外に1本も出たことがないのに読みやすい欧文フォントを
つくっています
まあ小さい時から文字全般に興味があったんですね文字のデザインの仕事を始めて最初
は日本の感じのデザインをしてました
でそれで左側にあるヘルマンチャップさんの本と出会って
する読んだ後でこれはチャップさんと同じようにペンを持って勉強すれば
欧文フォントがわかるかもしれないそう思って論文に行きました
でロンドンの街を歩き回っている時に小さい本屋で見つけたのがこの写真右の
アドリアン frutiger さんの音です
これらの本を読んでいとまぁ文字を読むこと
ものを見ることがどういうことか少しわかった気がします
いろんな人から日本人に欧文フォントなんかできるわけないよと言われたんですけど私
ができると思っていました
だって日本人でも世界的な舞台で活躍している人っていっぱいいるじゃないですか
例えばオーケストラの指揮者とか西洋料理のシェフだっている
そしてドイツの会社では日本でへ
憧れていたデザインの巨匠と一緒に仕事をすることができました
で実際に彼らからもたくさん学びましたし作り終えたフォントをを見て彼らも満足して
くれました
で
そういう仕事ができるというのはたぶんイギリスで一生懸命いろんなものを見てきた
からじゃないかなと思うんですよね
街を歩き回ったり
石を掘る工芸家のところに泊まりに行って勉強したりあるいは美しい活字の本に出会っ
たりしました
いっぺんに全部が理解できたと思いませんけれどもそれを何でもいいから見てそれでに
日本に帰ってきたのが1990年です
日本の空港に降り立った時に周りを見て日本の英文の見え方がなんかロンドンと違うな
というふうに感じました
同じ英文を使っているのになんで見え方が違うんだろうすることを考えたわけですで
読みやすさとか読み方のリズムとかそういったことって何だろうということを考えまし
た
ああああああ
まあここは大学なのでこの犬バーせキーという単語でちょっと実験してみましょう
割と長めの単語ですよねこれを1文字ずつ読んでいるかというとまあそうでもないです
よね
実際はこれはの単語の形
輪郭をひとめて
捉えてそれで単語を理解しているわけです
まあこの形が崩れたら読みにくいですよね
一つ一つの字は読めるのに単語の塊としてはちょっと読みにくい
もう一つですけどリズム感も大事ですよね文字が黒で印刷されるとするとその苦労の
文字と文字との間の白い部分
この部分も非常に重要なんですけどもこれが台無しになるとやっぱり読みにくい
で元に戻すとまあこのリズム感安心できますよね
このリズム感というのは例えば意識しないで歩いている時の歩幅
みたいなもので
何かこう無理やり何かしようとすると途端にギクシャクしてしまうそんなもんじゃない
でしょうか
文字も同じです
駅や空港それから街の中でいろんな案内
サインがあります
まあ
これをつくっている人はいるわけですよねこの文字を作っている人がいる
でも皆さんなかなかそこまで考えたことはない
実際に例えば今日この会場に来るときにいろんな
案内を見てそれでここにたどり着いているわけですけれどもその時のフォントがどんな
形だったかって覚えてますか
多分覚えてないと思うんですよねそれが覚えてないということは気にならなかった問題
がなかったということで問題なくたどり着けた
その問題はフォントデザイナーとかこのサインを作る人たちとかがあらかじめ取り除い
ているわけです
で
その苦労もにやはり日本の中でこういったものを見るとよくわかるんですけども
ちょっと残念な使われ方をしていることがあってこの欧文書体のデザイナーという女
から見て
でそのデザイナーもやはり普通の生活の中に入れば本も読むし
街の中に出ればこういったサインも見ますそういったところを見るとやっぱりこう
もうちょっと何とか改善できることがあるんじゃないかなというふうに
思います
近年のヨーロッパではここ調査を考えたフォントが主流になりつつあって
世界の空港や駅などで使われている frutiger というフォントを使った
サインが
多くなっていますさっき写真に出てもらった
アーティアンフルティアさんが作りました
ヨーロッパで全般的に使われているフォントは文字の懐つまり空間部分を広く取った
デザインですね
日本ではまだしっかり巻き込んだ文字が主流な感じがします
はいではちょっと比較してみましょうか上が helvetica という答えしたが
frutiger という人たいです
まあ別にはっきり見えている状態だと取ってもどちらも問題なく読めるというふうに
思うかも知れませんでも夕方とか
悪天候だとかそういった条件の悪いことを考えてみてください
ちょっと同じ程度ぼやかしてシミュレーション
してみますね
こんな風にするといっぺんにその読み朝に差が出てくるのがわかると思います
まあドイツではこういう実験の結果を受けて2013年に教師器などに使われる
フォントの木ストを発表していて振りティアというフォントがそこで推奨されています
日本ではその巻き込みが強い幅広のフォン等を選んで
しかも掲示板に収まらないからといってもう文章全体を左右から縮めに傾向があります
けれども読みやすくはないですよね
で文字と文字との秋はまるで無駄なスペースと思われているような感じがしますこれも
もう一度同じくらい大切なんです
ただ
左右の幅に限りがあるということも十分理解できます
そういうところのためにへ
コンデンスたいと呼ばれるフォントをまあ種類があるわけですけれども
ただ左右を縮めたわけではなくてフォントのデザイナーがあらかじめ
縮めたときの見え方がどうなるか調整しているわけですね
どういう調整をしているかと言うと
まあこれは縦棒も横棒の同じ太さで作った h です
横棒の方太く見えませんか
であとは横棒がちょっと下がって見えませんかこれは目の錯覚によるものですよね
で本当にする時にはその目の錯覚を取り除いておきます
あるいは
この声援を左右から潰すと綺麗な台になるでしょうかならないんですよね
自然に落ちたい形を事前に落ち着いた形の方が目に心地よいはずです
そういった目に心地よい補正のされた
コンデンス体が例えばアメリカではこんな風に使っているし
ドイツあの道路の名前とか結構長いですけれどもあらかじめこう
左右にこう縮めたコンテンツ帯を使っているわけです
幅広フォントを選んでから採用縮小するのでなくちゃんとそういったフォントを選んで
いるわけですね
一方この東京の例はどうでしょうか
これちょっと読みやすいでしょうか
これは a 東京の渋谷のバス停ですけれどもこんなふうに組まれています
これを
えまあ
frutiger で先ほどスイスの
高速道路の例で見た frutiger に置き換えてみると
書体をちょっと変えるだけでいい正体を適材適所という言葉はありますけれどもそう
いった書体を選ぶだけでこんな風に見え方が美しくなるし
読みやすくなりますね
さてこれだけでももう十分読みやすくなっているんですけどもう一つ
これのもっと読みやすくするヒントがあるんですね今これを全部大文字だけで組んで
ますけれどもこれを大文字と小文字で組んだら
その方がもっと読みやすいですよね
まあ単語の形がはっきりわかるので一瞬で理解しやすい
いろんな形のフォントがありますこれはスイスの例ですけれども
時にはまるで声のように言葉の表情
を与えてくれますねで
一方数の
必要な時には目立つけれども必要でないときにはそんなに目立たないそういった
フォントを作る人たちがいるということも
ここで覚えておいていただきたいと思います a
普段何気なく通り過ぎている標識ですけれどもこんなふうにいろんな工夫が隠されて
いるということを
ここで覚えて帰っていただきたいと思いますどうもありがとうございます
[拍手]